[Music]
I'm Phil bden I'm the agronomist with um
pulse Agronomy
Australia uh X pulse Australia and X
DPI uh I specialize in Pest Management
Farmers should be um monitoring um at
the moment particularly for
aphids The Usual Suspects of um green
peach aphid and cabbage aphid uh we
often see at this time of year and the
one of most concern is green Peach aord
because it's high chemical
resistance and also the fact that it
will transfer virus very quickly into
into
plants um in general though you know a
lot of these aphids are pretty well
controlled by a lot of the natural
enemies yeah you should be seeing uh
evidence of parasitism you know from the
parasitic wasps
uh you might see Lady Bole ly hoverfly
ly and lacewing ly that are are um very
capable of keeping uh those uh Apen
pests in check uh if you're not seeing
it though um well I guess you have to
make a decision whether you need to
spray uh the current recommendation uh
would be for one of the soft chemicals
um uh pamore
transform um are the two that are are
currently um used with with good effect
they don't affect um uh the beneficial
insects the with the latest canala
varieties that are often very vigorous
you those varieties can often outgrow
damage but um yeah it's just a matter of
uh monitoring regularly uh to see what's
in the crop I mean that's I guess the
basic principle of
integrated Pest Management is out there
monitoring regularly uh systematically
so that you you know what's you know
what you're dealing with in the
crop grazing can have an effect on uh
keeping pests in check but it's
usually uh when the grazing pressure is
very high yeah so you'll still have
residual pest numbers after grazing so
that's when it's important like to to
just go and uh monitor regularly uh to
um see what you're dealing with in in
the field after grazing and then you
know after grazing farmers are often top
dressing so that's getting the crop off
um to a um higher growth uh rate um as
well that can help and you know with a
lot of the current varieties that are
very vigorous they will outgrow any
damage so very rarely that at this time
of year that we need to intervene with a
chemical getting back to our basic
principles of integrated Pest Management
it's out there checking regularly
monitoring that you uh so you know what
you're dealing with then you can make
decisions about whether there
are um natural enemies there that are
keeping it under control or whether you
have to use a um a chemical um and or or
other management um
tool there are lots of resources
available uh the most um high-profile
one is probably PESA which is a uh a
service that's offered by uh Caesar
group from Melbourne University and that
relies on uh farmers and
agronomists uh sending them information
whenever they
see uh you
know anomalies in crops or they they
want identification done uh they have a
very good service and that's usually you
know taking a photo of any uh unusual
occurrence they might see in a crop
whether it's distorted leaves or you
know signs or symptoms of the pests and
they need it identified it can be done
through pests or through local Land
Services uh with um their um local uh
agronomists and they will send it on to
uh well Caesar or myself or someone to
get it get it identified so there are
resources there uh there's quite a bit
of um uh written material there uh notes
for example which is a
GC uh resource on on on the website um
and pulse Australia website is still
active uh they can they can be used to
uh help with um PES identification